connaissez-vous la forêt de Brocéliande
officiellement la forêt de Paimpont
mais non Paimpont une commune de
Bretagne située dans le département
d'Ille-et-Vilaine elle est le théâtre de
légendes et de mythes fascinant je suis
sûr que vous avez déjà entendu parler du
roi Arthur des Chevaliers de la Table
Ronde de la fée Morgan c'est aussi dans
cette forêt que ce cacherait Merlin
l'enchanteur Evan le breton de la team
épicurieux est parti à sa recherche oui
et je ne suis pas le seul à le chercher
amis car Brocéliande est une forêt où la
frontière entre mythe et réalité est un
peu flou ici il y a près de 400 000
visiteurs qui viennent découvrir une
vingtaine de sites tous liés aux
légendaires turiel autrement dit aux
histoires du roi Arthur de ses amis mais
aussi de ses ennemis
[Musique]
la plupart de ces légendes sont nées au
Moyen-Âge entre le 12e et le 13e siècle
pour évoquer ce bagage culturel on
utilise souvent l'expression matière de
Bretagne mais en réalité ces histoires
ne sont pas né en Bretagne mais de
l'autre côté de la Manche en 1137
l'évêque Gallois Geoffroy de bonne mars
publient un livre intitulé l'histoire
des rois de Bretagne mais la Bretagne
n'ont-ils parlent c'est la
Grande-Bretagne qu'on appelle à l'époque
l'île de Bretagne et non notre Bretagne
armoricaine il donne alors vie à un roi
légendaire nommé Arthur c'est un
guerrier sans peur à la tête d'un
immense empire rassemblant toute l'île
de Bretagne ainsi que l'Irlande
l'Islande la Norvège le Danemark et une
bonne partie de la Gaule Arthur est
quasiment invincible notamment grâce à
son conseiller Merlin l'enchanteur
c'est un magicien capable de maîtriser
tous les éléments le vent la pluie le
feu c'est un peu l'ancêtre d'Harry
Potter en compagnie des Chevaliers de la
Table Ronde Arthur et Merlin se lance en
quête du Saint Graal une mystérieuse
coupe qui aurait été utilisée par le
Christ et ses apôtres lors de son
dernier repas elle est censée assurer la
paix et la prospérité du royaume ce
roman est un best-seller au Moyen-Âge
pensez si bien que la légende d'Arthur
finit par franchir la Manche et
débarquer en France grâce à Chrétien de
Troyes l'auteur français en reprend tous
les ingrédients et si tu lui aussi la
forêt de Brocéliande en Grande-Bretagne
et non en Bretagne mais alors me
direz-vous comment la forêt de
Brocéliande s'est-elle retrouvée en
Ille-et-Vilaine et bien au 19e siècle le
chemin de fer arrive en Bretagne pour
attirer les touristes on n'hésite pas à
s'arranger avec ces vieilles légendes il
s'agit de fabriquer de toutes pièces
l'image d'une Bretagne typique et
romantique certains lieux sont alors
rebaptisés c'est le cas de la forêt de
Paimpont en Ille-et-Vilaine qu'on
associe à Brocéliande et la fameuse
forêt de Merlin l'enchanteur
bien sûr que Brocéliande est en Bretagne
et Merlin aussi je sais juste pas où il
se trouve mais mon petit doigt me dit
qu'il est probablement pas loin de cet
étang ni de cette épée magique j'ai déjà
vérifié pour vous il est pas sur la
plage contrairement aux apparences cette
épée n'est pas Excalibur elle s'appelle
l'épée des rois c'est elle qui a permis
à Arthur d'accéder au trône lorsque lors
d'un combat de chevalier il est le seul
à pouvoir la sortir de son rocher si
vous vous souvenez du dessin animé
Merlin l'enchanteur de Walt Disney c'est
plus ou moins l'histoire de l'épée des
rois qui est racontée Excalibur alors
Excalibur Evan c'est une autre épée
celle-ci l'épée la plus célèbre de la
légende arthurienne elle donna Arthur
une force surhumaine quant à son
fourreau il le protège de toutes les
blessures selon la légende
une fois dans la main du roi elle brille
plus fort que 30 torches
serait-ce la vraie mais attention le roi
Arthur n'en est pas le propriétaire il
en est le simple gardien le temps de son
règne c'est la fée Viviane dont Merlin
est très amoureux qui a demandé aux
Elfes de fabriquer cette épée pour
Arthur après qu'il est cassé la fameuse
épée du rocher elle a été forgée dans un
métal enchanté si dur que rien ne peut
le briser mais surtout elle a le pouvoir
d'assurer la victoire à son porteur
grâce à cette arme magique Arthur
réussit à rassembler tous les peuples de
Bretagne et de Grande-Bretagne et a
réunir autour de lui les plus valeureux
de ses chevaliers les fameux Chevaliers
de la Table Ronde à Kaamelott bon alors
il en est où Evan avec Merlin
l'enchanteur j'arrive les amis j'arrive
peut-être que Merlin l'enchanteur se
cache ici dans le Val sans Retour
l'endroit le plus visité de la forêt de
Brocéliande ferait que je vous conseille
vivement de visiter avec des compteurs
ou des conteuses ce sont des
professionnels qualifiés qui se
documentent qui du coup il les archives
qui lisent de nombreux livres pour vous
raconter les vraies histoires de
Brocéliande notamment celle du Val sans
Retour cette partie de la forêt serait
ensorcelée approchez-vous je vais vous
raconter l'histoire jadis la fée Morgan
la demi-sœur du roi Arthur était très
amoureuse d'un chevalier Guillaume art
sauf que celui-ci il l'a trompé alors
elle a jeté un charme sur tout le fond
de la vallée qui dit que tout homme s'il
a été trompeur et même en pensée ne
pourra plus jamais sortir du Val sans
Retour bon normalement moi je devrais
réussir à en sortir
vous avez vu cet arbre c'est l'emblème
de Brocéliande ça aurait pu faire une
bonne cachette pour Merlin mais en
réalité l'arbre n'a rien à voir avec les
histoires de la légende arthurienne et
non rien à voir cet arbre étrange que
l'on appelle l'Arbre d'Or est en réalité
une œuvre d'art créée sur place à la
suite d'un terrible incendie en
septembre 1990 deux mégafeux dévastent
plusieurs centaines d'hectares de landes
et de forêt du Val sans Retour les
dégâts sont-elles qu'un gigantesque élan
de solidarité s'organise dans la région
l'association du valsant retour entouré
de milliers de bénévoles replantent plus
de 500 000 arbres à Brocéliande pour
célébrer l'événement le sculpteur
François Davin crée cette oeuvre à
partir d'un châtaignier calciné dont la
silhouette rappelle les bois d'un cerf
il l'a recouvert de 5000 feuilles d'or
entourées de 5 chaînes noircis l'Arbre
d'Or symbolise le caractère fragile et
précieux de la forêt d'ailleurs en 20
les deux les flammes ont à nouveau
ravagé le sud du Val sans Retour comme
pour nous rappeler que la forêt est
fragile bon Evan tu l'as trouvé Merlin
c'est peut-être une chance de le trouver
ici tu entends ce cœur qui bat jamais
c'est peut-être Merlin ou pas la légende
raconte que l'on peut entendre deux
cœurs battre dans ce rocher on l'appelle
le rocher des faux amants encore un coup
de la fée Morgan qui était éperdument
amoureuse du chevalier guillaumard
qu'elle a surpris dans les bras d'une
autre alors ni une ni deux elle les a
changé en rocher mais un rocher qui a la
forme d'un cœur brisé comme le coeur de
Morgane autre preuve que cette forêt est
magique Jamie la couleur de la terre et
de la roche ce serait peut-être bien un
coup de Merlin non désolé Evan je vais
encore te décevoir si les rochers autour
de toi sont de couleur violette ou rouge
ça n'a rien à voir avec la magie il
s'agit de schiste rouge une roche très
commune en Bretagne et plus
particulièrement là où tu te trouves à
Brocéliande ande et certains disent
aussi que c'est le sang des faits qui se
serait déversé partout dans Brocéliande
jusqu'à en teinter la terre mais bon
bref Jamie revenons-en à notre quête de
Merlin je crois avoir trouvé une
nouvelle piste
la fontaine de Barenton elle est cité
dans de nombreux textes depuis 1160
comme étant une fontaine magique qui
fait des bulles ce serait sa façon de
communiquer avec les humains moments
fontaine de Barenton dis-moi où se cache
Merlin l'enchanteur je le cherche
partout depuis une heure
visiblement la réponse ne coule pas de
source d'après la légende Merlin aurait
enchanté la fontaine d'eau pour
apprendre à Viviane ça bien-aimé à faire
tomber la pluie une autre légende
affirme que les faits naissent dans ses
bulles bon c'est mignon mais il y a une
autre explication d'abord il faut savoir
que la température de cette eau est
glaciale entre 4 et 10 degrés ces bulles
ne se sont donc pas formés comme les
geysers en Islande sous l'effet de la
chaleur elles sont liées à un dégagement
de gaz principalement de l'azote pas
dangereux c'est le principal composant
de l’air que nous respirons il serait dû
à la décomposition organique remontant
par une sorte de siphon formé dans les
coups géologiques sous la fontaine c'est
la faible solubilité de la zone dans
l'eau qui explique le dégagement des
bulles en surface voilà Evan tu l'as ta
réponse claire comme de l'eau de roche
non moi je crois surtout que cette
fontaine est vraiment magique et je ne
suis pas le seul à le penser car des
centaines de visiteurs viennent chaque
jour ici pour se recueillir pour se
ressourcer voire même pour buller
justement je trouve qu'on bulle un peu
trop nous ce qu'on cherche ces Merlin
c'est quand même trouvé son tombeau
Jamie parce que les gens prennent pour
son tambeau car entre vous et moi Merlin
n'est pas vraiment enterré ici en fait
il est partout dans la forêt car Merlin
a été victime d'un sort de la fée
Viviane qui par amour pour lui l'a
enfermé dans une prison d'air afin qu'il
reste à ses côtés pour l'éternité donc
concrètement Merlin pourrait très bien
être à la cime des arbres ou pourquoi
pas derrière ce rocher
bon Merlin j'en ai marre de te chercher
partout si tu existes vraiment prouve-le
en me transformant je sais pas moi en
prince de Brocéliande
c'est moi Evan aide-moi Evan alors là la
science la science comme tu dis je crois
qu'elle ne peut plus rien pour toi voilà
si vous avez envie d'embrasser une
grenouille pour Kevin sera incarne en
être humain n'hésitez pas à nous le
faire savoir j'espère que vous avez
apprécié cette vidéo que tout comme moi
elle vous a enchanté on se retrouve très
vite dimanche prochain d'ici là chers
épicurieuse et épicurieux passé une
excellente semaine la plus magique
possible
[Applaudissements]